si vous le voulez tout de suite nous
allons regarder ce film
salut à tous il y à quelques temps je
vous invite à proposer un sujet pour un
épisode de la chaîne et en commentaire
vous avez été nombreux à vouloir un
épisode sur la mode vestimentaire à
travers différentes époques
pour être tout à fait franche n'était
pas hyper enthousiasme est un thème
parce que c'est typiquement le genre de
sujet où on a vite fait de se coincer
dans une présentation scolaire simple
l'inr celle qu on vous livre dans quasi
toutes les histoires du costume ou vous
explique que tu es le roi en choisissant
tel costume modifie instantanément la
mode et les moeurs de son époque
le problème c'est que dans les faits ça
ne se passe pas comme ça déjà en 1957
roland barthes et je me suis pas mal
inspiré d'un de ses textes pour cet
épisode soulevé trois problèmes à ce
type de présentation problème numéro un
c'est celui de la temporalité le fait de
présenter de façon chronologique
l'évolution d'un vêtement et bien ça
nous fait confondre le moment où il est
inventé et celui où il devient la norme
par exemple en 1906 est inventé le
premier soutien gorge par paul poiret
pour remplacer le corset mais dans la
réalité il ne sera accepté est porté par
une majorité des femmes que dans les
années 20 second problème c'est que les
histoires qu'on nous raconte ne s'occupe
que du costume royal ou aristocratiques
comme si le roi était le référent du
vêtement et que la parure était plus
importante que les guêtres de
jacquouille troisième et dernier
problème c'est qu'on ne se demande pas
assez calé la fonction d'un vêtement la
raison pour laquelle il a été créé pour
toutes ces raisons et bien j'ai décidé
de ne pas faire une vidéo sur l'histoire
de la mode comme c'était prévu
man panique je vais quand même vous
parlez du vêtement ce qu'il faut bien
avoir à l'esprit c'est qu'un vêtement
est toujours conçus en fonction d'une
époque d'un pays et d'une classe sociale
savez vous par exemple que l'opposition
classique mode féminine mode masculine
tel qu'on nous la présente dans les
magasins n'est pas toujours valable pour
toutes les époques puisque vième siècle
avant jésus-christ les femmes peuvent
porter le pantalon et durant l'antiquité
les grecs et les romains étaient des
adeptes des tuniques et des toges tant
pour les femmes que pour les hommes
on peut envisager les choses d'une autre
façon en anthropologie par exemple il
existe bien une opposition mais qui
distingue les vêtements cousus des
vêtements drapés les vêtements drapés et
bien c'est ce que j'ai évoquée avec la
toge des romains ce sont des tissus dans
lesquels s'enroule les individus par
contre faut pas croire que les vêtements
drapés sont portés parce qu'on ne sait
pas coudre et que les vêtements cousus
serait réservé aux civilisations plus
avancé depuis le paléolithique les
hommes cous et les nombreuses aiguille
achats retrouvés lors de fouilles le
prouve ce sont sans doute les derniers
solutréen de la dordogne ou du
nord-ouest de l'espagne qui ont inventé
ce type d lui tailler dans l'os ou le
bois de rennes ille environ vingt mille
ans l'homme de cro magnon cousez
beaucoup et cousez fin ce qui implique
des vêtements élaboré le climat rude de
cette période nous laisse aussi penser
que le vêtement couvrait entièrement le
corps on est loin du cliché de la peau
de bête découpé à la rage pour faire
passer les bras et la tête
si c'est pas une question d' avancées
technologiques pourquoi alors des
populations choisissent pendant des
siècles le vêtements drapés et d'autres
s'attachent à confectionner des
vêtements cousus les anthropologues
établissent de nouveaux une distinction
entre les vêtements tropicaux qui sont
conçus pour les régions chaudes et les
vêtements septentrionaux conçu pour les
régions froides les peuples
méditerranéens comme les grecs ou les
romains porter la toge parce que le
climat tempéré de la région le
permettait de ses tenues anti que je
peux vous citer les plus connus qui sont
keaton et péplum et qui se portent l'une
par dessus l'autre se sont simplement de
large pièce des tofs rectangulaire en
laine ou en coton draper autour du corps
maintenu à la taille par une ou deux
ceintures et sur l'épaule par une fibule
la fibule étant l'ancêtre de la broche
ou de l'épinglé à nourrice
si les grecs et les romains adopte la
toge c'est aussi parce qu'ils
considèrent que le vêtement cousu et
celui des barres d'arrêt en particulier
les peuples du nord de l'europe
anecdote rapide au passage nous allons
une image très épurée du style
vestimentaire pour les périodes d
antiques
on imagine souvent ses robes et toge
d'un blanc immaculé et en réalité il
rien nous savons aujourd'hui grâce aux
études sur les fresques et la
polychromie que les ti supportée par les
classes aisées était colorée du rouge du
jaune du vert est orné de motifs des
fleurs et des animaux des tons vifs qui
contraste avec les statues de marbre
blanc qu'on peut voir dans les musées
d'ailleurs la plupart des statues
antiques était colorée la zone
simplement perdu leurs pigments
d'origine on peut en voir la trace au
microscope sur certaines d'entre elles
comme la dame d'auxerre que vous pouvez
aller voir au louvre maintenant essayons
de répondre à des questions assez
basique
ça sert à quoi un vêtement on a tendance
à dire que l'homme s'habille par pudeur
ou pour se protéger ou pour se sublimer
ou les trois à la fois c'est pas
étonnant qu'on pense bien souvent qu
parures et vêtements de luxe des classes
dirigeantes et aristocratique puisque ce
sont elles que l'on représente sur les
fresques les tableaux les objets d'art
presque tout ce que les historiens et
les archéologues ont à se mettre sous la
dent pourtant de toutes les sociétés
traditionnelles
c'est la société rurale qui a connu les
phénomènes de mode les plus marquants
ses costumes qu'on dit aujourd'hui
folklorique était très important pour
les sociétés qui les ont conçus pour
quoi et bien parce que les fonctions
d'un vêtement était multiple une
broderie sur une chemise servait à la
décorer mais en même temps un masque et
les coutures indiqué statut social de
son propriétaire et aussi d'autres
informations comme l'âge le sexe si la
personne est mariés ou célibataires
si elle est en deuil mais ça se retrouve
sur la plupart des chemises
traditionnelles d'europe en ac douanes
en grèce en norvège on recouvre donc pas
son corps simplement par pudeur il ya
c'est vrai chez l'homme la nécessité de
se couvrir de se protéger du froid des
intempéries mais il ya surtout la
volonté soit de se singulariser soin de
se conformer à la mode mais c'est quoi
la mode au juste une mode vestimentaire
elles soient adoptées soient contestées
donc chaque individu participe à la mode
prenons l'exemple de la cravate certains
s'y soumettent mécaniquement chaque jour
et d'autre la rejette totalement ce qui
fait la mode c'est avant tout le degré
de participation plus il ya de personnes
qui adoptent un costume plus celui ci
est un repère dans la société met donc
comment naît une mode faut bien
comprendre que tout habib est au départ
un geste on se couvre qui ensuite
réglementée comment le porte quand ou
avec qui nous dès qu'une société met en
place des codes vestimentaires et
le vêtement qui est un simple tissu
devient costumes
c'est ce que roland barthes et ferdinand
de chaussures de saussure pardon
expliqué en rappelant qu'un costume
c'est avant tout la manière de se vêtir
particulière un pays une époque une
condition plutôt qu'un objet purement
esthétique et ce costume si les
largement que c'était pas la société
enel devient un objet de mode
pas de code pas de costume pas de
costume pas de mode pas de mode
pas de mode donc pour résumer pas de
code
pas de mode un costume à cause d'une
panne mode manuel à notre attaque
possible que suzanne est un acte au 3
mai d'accord ça a dû en perdre certains
noms ouais vous devez vous demander si
ça a réellement une importance si je
suis pas en train de vous embêter avec
un truc dont personne n'a à faire bah en
fait ça a son importance parce que nous
y sommes confrontés chaque jour
tous les matins on fait un choix
vestimentaire certainement rester en
pyjama d'autres vont enfiler une tenue
de travail que leur entreprise leur a
délivré le costume si vous voulez ça
ressemble langage ça un code et sa
transmet des messages
prenons les noms de concret si vous êtes
au travail que vous portez un costard et
que vous enlevez le pantalon ya de
fortes chances pour que vous soyez
ridicule parce que vous venez de
détruire l'ensemble le système du
vêtement par contre si vous enlevez tout
sauf le caleçon et que vous retrouvez
sur une plage alors là ça va vous ne
fait plus rire puisque c'est une tenue
pour se baigner en changement de
contexte social vous vous êtes sauvés
des moqueries parce que vous avez
réintégré le code vestimentaire on
caricature un peu mais beaucoup
l'histoire tourne autour de ce principe
notamment lors de la venue d'un
dirigeant africain portant la toque de
léopard parce que c'est l'insigne de son
rang alors en europe il fait rire en
afrique pas du tout où paraît désordre à
celui qui ne reconnaît pas le code
pourquoi ce habitons pour répondre à
cette question et bien on va parler des
sociétés qui ne s'habille pas ou presque
pas l'homme se couvre surtout pour des
raisons sociales puisque pour des
raisons physiques
c'est à dire protéger son corps du
soleil du froid des intempéries en
papouasie nouvelle guinée les vêtements
du quotidien peuvent être extrêmement
simple un étui pénien pour les hommes et
pour les
jupe qui tombe au genou cette simplicité
s'efface totalement lors de rencontres
publiques hors du village
bref pour une occasion spéciale les
hommes deviennent méconnaissables tous
parés de plumes de casoar dans les
cheveux et d'une défense de porc piqué
d'emmener sans oublier une accumulation
de colliers les femmes se présentent
aussi avec des colliers très élaborés
mais n'ont pas le droit aux parures de
tête
les travaux des tno archéologie menée
notamment par anne marie et pierre
petrikin ont permis de distinguer
clairement les enjeux rôles du vêtement
chez ces populations
la parure ça sert à mettre en valeur les
corps parfois les protégés d esprit des
maléfices on dit alors qu'ils ont une
fonction prophylactiques et à se
distinguer des autres sociétés présentes
sur l'île c'est aussi un moyen pour les
hommes d'affirmer leur virilité il n'y a
pas que les papous qui vivent nus l'eia
manas de terre de feu les aborigènes
d'australie et les fans du kalahari le
milieu naturel de ces populations
le désert la forêt équatoriale humide
les montagnes la steppe donc des climats
d'exception dans lesquelles les
individus se passe quasi totalement de
vêtements chez les populations des
milieux humides
il est même coutu de se déshabiller
lorsqu'il pleut car un corps humain nu
sèche rapidement et c'est bien ce que
faisait les fuchsias habitants de la
terre de feu en patagonie sans trop de
problèmes pendant des siècles jusqu'à ce
qu'arrive à la fin du 19ème
démissionnaire d'europe qui choqués par
la nudité de ces peuples leur distribuer
vers des vêtements et des couvertures
dit comme ça on pourrait penser que
c'est une belle initiative de la part
des colons par contre ce qui est moins
sympa c'est que ces couvertures étaient
porteuses de virus européen type grippe
rougeole syphilis et pneumonies des
maladies que les indiens ne tardèrent
pas à contracter à force de grelotter
dans des habits détrempée ils ont
d'ailleurs été totalement exterminée de
cette façon
puisqu'on en est à parler de nudité et
avant de se quitter il ya une précision
apportée il ne faut pas confondre la
nudité et nudisme la nudité n'est pas le
nudisme qui est cette doctrine prônant
la vie au grand air dans un état de
complet tu lui dis tu es ce retour à la
nature et je mets des guillemets n'a
rien à voir avec la nudité d'époque
convient de présenter et on est même
très loin
je m'explique si le résultat est le même
le nudisme n'est pas une pratique
quotidienne mais plutôt une construction
intellectuelle par anticonformisme par
opposition et donc c'est plutôt un
retournement de l'ordre social qui est
volontaire
on dit que se vêtir et le propre de
l'homme ornements ou instruments le
vêtement apporte un confort certain en
créant à même notre peau un microclimat
que l'on peut emporter avec lui il est
vrai que la plupart du temps peut
toutefois s'en passer mais le vêtement
rend bien des services dans les milieux
les plus hostiles que serait amstrong
sans sa combinaison d'astronaute et que
serait cousteau son scaphandre
voilà et bien tout est réglé en tout cas
nous sommes ravis de vous avant c'est la
fin de cet épisode
merci à tous de l'avoir regardé
n'hésitez pas à partager le lit quai et
à me laisser vos impressions
commentaires petites annonces avant de
se quitter vous pouvez dès à présent
soutenir financièrement les missions via
un tipi qui est une plateforme de
financement participatif
vous trouverez les liens dans la part de
descriptions sous la vidéo et sur la
page d'accueil de ma chaîne c'est
vraiment le partage des vidéos et le
soutien financier si vous en avez les
moyens évidemment qui font que cette
émission pourra durer dans tous les cas
merci beaucoup d'être ici et je vous dis
à très vite
salut